I am Nicolas be with Matt Welch this is
ask a libertarian 2012 wait while you
have time check out our book in
paperback it's just coming out it's the
Declaration of Independence
Sebastian Harris asks us via Facebook
how do you plan on uniting various
libertarians some of us are on the right
some on the left many are atheist while
some are religious and socially tolerant
how do you keep the Annette on narco
capitalist in line with the moderate
libertarians and how do we convince
people that we aren't anarchists who
believe in rape distribution of hard
drugs and zero regulation whatsoever man
well seriously how do we keep the
anarcho-capitalists in line I want you
to think about that a little bit more I
don't understand this tendency
necessarily this desire to unite
everybody what's the point especially if
you're a bunch of libertarians which
mean you're you're kind of bred to
disagree with one another there are
substantial philosophical differences
between various schools of libertarian
thought there are plenty of libertarians
out there who consider me and or Nick
but especially Nick as being beyond the
pale for one reason or another and that
is kind of as it should be these people
who believed strongly in various
philosophical strands and once you're
into philosophy that's pretty black and
white stuff or at least it can be
reasons outlook always has been kind of
more broad-based we're an outreach
magazine we want to talk about kind of
the impulses of libertarian broadly
understood and talk about that with the
rest of the world
I don't think libertarians need to unite
for what purposes you know do you want
to do you want to elect a president you
want to throw a party I'm not a softball
thing you want to have a softball team
to be the White House like the the drug
reformers did apparently it today or
yesterday so I'm not convinced that it
is a goal that we need to worry about
too much and we should all disagree with
one each other with one another
vigorously I think it improves everybody
you know for me I'm not interested in
foundations per se I look forward to a
better world but not a utopian world and
one of the ways that I think about
policy and movements of libertarian
movements is is this next step going to
make us free or less
and I often talk about this with friends
of mine who are in drug policy I would
welcome marijuana legalization I don't
think it should stop there but I'm not
gonna say you know until all drugs are
legal we can't move towards
decriminalization or ending the
prohibition say on marijuana and other
what used to be called soft drugs I
think that makes sense across
libertarian perspectives I grew that we
don't all have to we certainly shouldn't
think with one mind but I think there's
broad agreement that we can move towards
better things rather than stay stuck in
really bad situations and if the
Philosopher's can toughen up the
pragmatists and vice versa I think
that's only a good thing this is ask a
libertarian 2012 stay tuned here for
more of your questions and keep them on
coming